Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. A sudden blow. The great wings beating still above the staggering girl, her thighs caressed by the dark webs, her nape caught in his bill. He holds her helpless breast upon his breast. How can those terrified vague fingers
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。突如其来的一击。巨大的双翼仍在惊恐的少女上方拍打，她的大腿被那黑暗的蹼足爱抚，她的后颈被他的喙紧紧钳住。他将她无助的胸脯按在自己的胸前。那些惊恐而无力的手指，怎能
push the feathered glory from her loosening thighs? And how can body laid in that white rush but feel the strange heart beating where it lies? A shudder in the loins engenders there the broken wall, the burning roof and tower and Agamemnon dead. Being so caught up, so mastered by the brute blood of the air did she put on his knowledge with his power before the indifferent beak could let her drop that is wb yates's poem leader and the swan and tom it is describing one of the most famous women not just in all antiquity or in all mythology, but who arguably ever lived, if she did live, and that is Helen of Troy, by repute, the most beautiful woman who ever existed, the most beautiful woman in the Greek world, the face that launched a thousand ships,
将那羽毛覆盖的荣耀从她松开的大腿上推开？那躺在白色冲撞中的躯体，怎能不感受到那奇异的心脏在身下跳动？腰间的战栗孕育了破碎的城墙、燃烧的屋顶与塔楼，以及阿伽门农的死亡。既然被如此捕获，被那空中野蛮的血性所征服，她是否在冷漠的喙将她丢下之前，就已穿上了他的力量与智慧？这就是叶芝的诗作《丽达与天鹅》。汤姆，它描述的是不仅在古代或神话中，甚至在历史上（如果她确实存在过）最著名的女性之一，那就是特洛伊的海伦。据传，她是史上最美的女人，希腊世界最美的女人，那张引发了千艘战舰出征的脸庞，
the person whose abduction kick-started the Trojan War. So the woman who is at the centre of arguably the most influential epic narrative ever written. Yeah. So Tom, I know you're a huge fan of Helen of Troy. Love Helen of Troy. But everyone loves Helen of Troy, don't they? I mean, that's the whole point. You deliberately gave me a very difficult poem to read with a ridiculous amount of stuff about loins and thighs.
那个因被劫持而引发特洛伊战争的人。所以，她是史上最具影响力的史诗叙事的核心人物。没错。汤姆，我知道你是特洛伊海伦的超级粉丝。我爱特洛伊海伦。但每个人都爱特洛伊海伦，不是吗？我的意思是，这正是重点所在。你故意给了我一首很难读的诗，里面还有那么多关于腰部和大腿的荒唐描写。
So thank you for that. No, you're welcome. Tell us what's going on in the poem. So in the poem, it's describing how Helen of Troy is conceived. And so in the passage you read so beautifully, the shudder in the loins engenders there the broken wall, the burning roof and tower, that is a reference to the sack of Troy. But it's not just Helen of Troy who is being conceived. There is another sister, Clytemnestra, who will go on to marry Agamemnon, who is the commander of the Greeks at Troy. And so that line, an Agamemnon dead, Clytemnestra may have a role
所以谢谢你了。不客气。告诉我们这首诗讲了什么。这首诗描述了特洛伊海伦是如何受孕的。在你刚才读得如此优美的段落中，“腰间的战栗孕育了破碎的城墙、燃烧的屋顶与塔楼”，这是对特洛伊城陷落的指涉。但不仅是特洛伊海伦在受孕，还有另一个姐妹，克吕泰涅斯特拉，她后来嫁给了特洛伊战争中希腊联军的统帅阿伽门农。所以那句“以及阿伽门农的死亡”，克吕泰涅斯特拉可能在其中
to play in that. So we'll be looking at Clytemnestra, Helen of Troy's sister, as well as Helen of Troy. But just on this poem, which you read so beautifully and without any pauses because you were losing it over certain phrases, it is about a rape. It is about Zeus, the king of the gods, who has disguised himself as a swan. And he is a serial rapist and he's invariably disguising himself to do this. So he disguises himself as a share of gold or as the husband of the woman that he's coming to. But here he has come as a swan. And what is exceptional about this rape relative to earlier rapes that Zeus has perpetrated, earlier rapes, he fathers heroes, male heroes on the women that he has taken but here he
扮演了角色。因此，我们不仅会关注特洛伊海伦，也会关注她的姐妹克吕泰涅斯特拉。但就这首你读得如此优美且没有停顿（因为你被某些词句弄得语无伦次）的诗而言，它讲述的是一场强奸。这是关于众神之王宙斯，他伪装成天鹅。他是一个连环强奸犯，而且总是通过伪装来实施暴行。他有时伪装成金雨，有时伪装成他所接近的女人的丈夫。但在这里，他化身为天鹅。与宙斯之前犯下的强奸案相比，这次强奸的特殊之处在于，之前他与受害女性生下的都是男性英雄，但在这里，
is fathering for the first time a daughter and helen of troy is the only daughter that zeus ever fathers and this is why she is the most beautiful woman in the world all right yeah and you said she's reputed to be the most beautiful woman in the world i I mean, in the myth, she is the most beautiful woman in the world. There is no kind of, you know, oh, we all have different standards of beauty. Objectively, she's the most beautiful. And it reflects the way in which, in the Greek world, competition to be the best is the absolute essence of everything. I mean, it's what gives rise to the Olympics, for instance.
他第一次生下了一个女儿。特洛伊海伦是宙斯唯一的女儿，这就是为什么她是世界上最美的女人。好吧，你说她被公认为世界上最美的女人。我的意思是，在神话中，她就是世界上最美的女人。不存在什么“我们对美的标准不同”之类的说法。客观上，她就是最美的。这反映了希腊世界中竞争成为“最强”是万事万物的核心本质。我的意思是，这正是奥运会等赛事产生的原因。
And beauty contests are a feature of Greek culture, as every other kind of contest is. So Helen stands as the most beautiful of all. But there is this paradox in this sense of Helen as absolutely unique, which is that at the same time, she is actually only one of four children that Leda will give birth to. And when Leda gives birth to them, she hatches them. She gives birth to two eggs. That's what happens when you've been interfered with by a swan, right? I mean, that's the nature of swan-human relations. I mean, yes, it opens up many questions.
选美比赛是希腊文化的一个特征，就像其他各种竞赛一样。所以海伦作为最美的人脱颖而出。但这种将海伦视为绝对唯一性的观念中存在一个悖论，那就是她实际上只是丽达所生的四个孩子之一。当丽达生下他们时，她是把他们孵出来的。她生下了两枚蛋。这就是被天鹅干扰后会发生的事情，对吧？我的意思是，这就是天鹅与人类关系的本质。是的，这引发了许多问题。
She hatches two eggs. And in one of them, Helen comes out and a boy called Pollux. Oh, yeah, Castor and Pollux. Yes. And in the other egg, Clytemnestra, so Helen's half-sister, and Castor. Yeah. So two of the children are the children of Zeus, and two of them are the children of a mortal. And we'll come to the story of what is going on here, who Helen is, as told by the Greeks in due course.
她孵出了两枚蛋。其中一枚里出来的是海伦和一个叫波吕丢刻斯的男孩。哦，是的，卡斯托耳和波吕丢刻斯。没错。另一枚蛋里是克吕泰涅斯特拉，也就是海伦同母异父的姐妹，还有卡斯托耳。是的。所以其中两个孩子是宙斯的后代，另外两个是凡人的后代。我们稍后会讲到关于这里发生了什么、海伦是谁，以及希腊人是如何讲述这个故事的。
But just to say, I mean, this is coming off the back of an episode on Custer and we've been looking at the industrial society of America and all that kind of thing. And obviously talking about women laying eggs and being attacked by swans and things, I mean, it might seem very different, but of course we were talking about the power of myth in the context of the Lakota, weren't we? Or indeed of Custer. Custer is a mythological figure. But Custer would have no place for kind of talking animals or things like that. No, he'd stuff an animal, but he wouldn't talk to it. Exactly so. But in Greece, these stories have a kind of power and resonance of the kind that you would witness in the Cota society in the late 19th century. Just mention it because it gives a sense of how these stories are not just imaginative fantasies for children, which is often how Greek
但我想说的是，这紧接着我们关于卡斯特的剧集，我们一直在研究美国的工业社会等等。显然，谈论女性下蛋、被天鹅袭击之类的事情，看起来可能非常不同，但我们当然是在讨论拉科塔人背景下的神话力量，不是吗？或者卡斯特本人。卡斯特是一个神话人物。但卡斯特不会有那种会说话的动物之类的东西。不，他会把动物做成标本，但他不会和它说话。正是如此。但在希腊，这些故事具有一种你在19世纪末拉科塔社会中能见到的那种力量和共鸣。之所以提到这一点，是因为它让人感受到这些故事不仅仅是给孩子看的想象幻想，而这通常是希腊
myths are presented. They are terrifying stories. I mean, terrible things happen in them, but they channel aspects of Greek culture that are incredibly significant. And as you say, the idea of Helen as the face that launches a thousand ships, I mean, that's a line from a play by Christopher Marlowe, contemporary of Shakespeare. So that's almost 3,000 years after Helen of Troy is supposed to have lived. And there's still this kind of power. And philosophers have come up with this measure of beauty, which is a milli-Helen. And it's the amount of beauty that is sufficient to launch a ship. So Helen has a thousand Millie Helens. So the potency of the most beautiful woman in the world as a myth, I think, is very enduring. But there's also
神话被呈现的方式。它们是令人恐惧的故事。我的意思是，其中发生了可怕的事情，但它们传达了希腊文化中极其重要的方面。正如你所说，海伦是“那张引发了千艘战舰出征的脸庞”，那是莎士比亚同时代人克里斯托弗·马洛剧作中的一句台词。所以那是在特洛伊海伦被认为生活年代的近3000年后。这种力量依然存在。哲学家们甚至提出了一个美的衡量单位，叫“毫海伦”（milli-Helen）。它是足以引发一艘战舰出征的美丽程度。所以海伦有一千毫海伦。作为神话，世界上最美女性的效力我认为是非常持久的。但还有
the possibility that the stories that the Greeks in the classical period, so that's kind of sixth, fifth, fourth centuries BC, that they might be looking back to a much earlier period, the period of perhaps a historical Trojan War, a period when perhaps there were great queens. Well, people have always been fascinated by this, haven't they? The idea that maybe a queen was kidnapped. Maybe there was some dynastic marriage gone wrong that provokes a war between cities on different sides of the Aegean. Yes. So this also is part, I think, of the fascination of the stories of Helen of Troy.
一种可能性，即古典时期（即公元前六、五、四世纪）的希腊人所讲述的故事，可能是在回望一个更早的时期，一个或许存在历史上的特洛伊战争的时期，一个或许存在伟大女王的时期。人们一直对此很着迷，不是吗？那种认为可能有一位女王被绑架，可能是一场王朝联姻出了差错，从而引发了爱琴海两岸城市之间战争的想法。是的。所以我认为这也是特洛伊海伦故事令人着迷的一部分。
So to begin with, let's look at the life of Helen as told by the Greeks. Yeah. Brilliant. And this is basically, I've kind of stitched it together from various sources. So people are writing about it before Homer. He's not the first. Homer is the first, but Homer leaves lots of space. So he doesn't cover every aspect of her. Oh, so people fill it in afterwards. Yeah. And when Homer introduces Helen, he doesn't explain who she is. He is taking for granted that people already know who she is. She's already a folk figure, if you like. Yeah. And so the birth of Helen is something that is conceived by Zeus. And there is an epic that
首先，让我们来看看希腊人笔下的海伦的一生。是的，太棒了。我基本上是从各种来源中拼凑出来的。在荷马之前就有人在写关于她的故事了。他不是第一个。荷马是第一个，但荷马留下了很多空白。所以他并没有涵盖她生活的方方面面。哦，所以人们后来填补了这些空白。是的。当荷马介绍海伦时，他并没有解释她是谁。他理所当然地认为人们已经知道她是谁了。如果你愿意的话，她已经是一个民间人物了。是的。所以海伦的出生是宙斯构思出来的。有一部史诗
follows shortly after Homer called the Kypria. We only have fragments of it. And it explains how Zeus wants to destroy or rather winnow humanity. He wants to diminish it. And so there was a time when the countless tribes of men, though wide dispersed, oppressed the surface of the deep bosomed earth and Zeus saw it and had pity and in his wise heart resolved to relieve the alluring earth of men that the load of death might empty the world. And this is something that you get a lot in Near Eastern myths. So, you know, in the Bible, God sends a flood. You get the same in kind of Babylonian myth and so on. What's distinctive about this is that Zeus is advised by a character called Momos, or Blame, that this is really boring. He should go for something much more fun and that he should ensure the birth of two completely luminous and fatal figures. And one of them is the son of a nymph called Thetis. And Thetis, the prophecy is that her son will be greater than the father. And Zeus had been planning to marry her, but gets warned off by this. And so he marries her to a kind of rather dull hero called Peleus. And their son is called Achilles.
紧随荷马之后，名为《塞浦路斯史诗》。我们只保留了其中的片段。它解释了宙斯如何想要摧毁或者说筛选人类。他想要减少人口。因此，曾有一段时间，无数的人类部落，尽管分散在各地，却压迫着深邃大地表面，宙斯看到了这一点，心生怜悯，在他睿智的心中决定减轻大地对人类的负担，让死亡的重担清空世界。这在近东神话中很常见。所以，你知道，在《圣经》中，上帝降下了洪水。你在巴比伦神话中也能看到类似的情况，等等。这里的独特之处在于，宙斯受到一个叫莫莫斯（Momos），即“责备”的角色建议，说这太无聊了。他应该追求一些更有趣的事情，他应该确保两个完全光芒四射且致命的人物诞生。其中一个是宁芙女神忒提斯的儿子。关于忒提斯，预言说她的儿子将比父亲更伟大。宙斯曾计划娶她，但被这个预言劝阻了。于是他把她嫁给了一个相当平庸的英雄，名叫珀琉斯。他们的儿子就是阿喀琉斯。
Of heel fame. Of heel fame. And Achilles will be the greatest warrior on the field of Troy in the Trojan War. But he also decides that he will father a daughter. And so I think the last time we quoted Yeats was his great poem on the Easter Rising. And there's this phrase, a terrible beauty is born. And Helen is a terrible beauty. And that shudder in the loins, the shudder, I mean, there's a sense of dread as well as of pleasure about this. Because of the number of people who will lose their lives because of Helen, right? I mean, she's fatal. Absolutely. So where does Helen come from? So there are various stories. Greek myth is not like the Bible. There isn't a kind of single canonical account. Yeah. of the sea, so as in the famous Botticelli painting, that the foam hardens and becomes
以脚后跟闻名。以脚后跟闻名。阿喀琉斯将成为特洛伊战争中特洛伊战场上最伟大的战士。但他还决定要生一个女儿。我想我们上次引用叶芝是在他关于复活节起义的伟大诗作中。有这样一句话，“一种可怕的美诞生了”。海伦就是一种可怕的美。那种腰间的战栗，那种战栗，我的意思是，这既有一种恐惧感，也有一种愉悦感。因为海伦会导致那么多人丧生，对吧？我的意思是，她是致命的。绝对是。那么海伦从哪里来呢？所以有各种各样的故事。希腊神话不像《圣经》。没有一种单一的权威说法。是的。关于海洋，就像波提切利那幅著名的画作一样，泡沫变硬并变成了
a swan's egg and it's thrown into a swamp where it fertilizes and Helen hatches from it. So that's one story. That's just bizarre. I'm sorry, Tom. That's mad. Yeah, that is mad. That never happened. I think the thing about the swan is much more plausible. Well, so another story is that Zeus changes into a swan, but the person he rapes isn't Leda, it's Nemesis. So kind of retribution. And he either chases her across the world and they're constantly changing form, a bit like in the cartoon of The Sword in the Stone.
一个天鹅蛋，被扔进沼泽里受精，海伦就从里面孵化出来了。这是一个故事。这太离奇了。抱歉，汤姆。这太疯狂了。是的，那确实很疯狂。那从来没发生过。我认为关于天鹅的事情更可信。好吧，另一个故事是宙斯变成了天鹅，但他强奸的人不是丽达，而是涅墨西斯。所以这是一种报应。他要么在世界各地追逐她，他们不断变换形态，有点像《石中剑》动画片里的那样。
People have seen that. Oh, yeah. And another is that he pretends to be chased by an eagle and Nemesis takes the swan into her fold to shelter the swan and then the swan behaves disgracefully. And the eagle is Aphrodite in disguise. That's a complicated story. Very complicated. Which is why I think basically the version that becomes most popular and is told most often is the story that it is Leda who gets raped. And Leda is the queen of Sparta and her husband, the king of Sparta, is a man called Tyndareus.
人们看过那个。哦，是的。另一个是他假装被一只老鹰追赶，涅墨西斯把天鹅带进她的怀里保护它，然后天鹅表现得非常无耻。而那只老鹰是伪装的阿佛洛狄忒。那是一个复杂的故事。非常复杂。这就是为什么我认为基本上最流行、讲述次数最多的版本是丽达被强奸的故事。丽达是斯巴达王后，她的丈夫，斯巴达国王，是一个叫廷达瑞俄斯的人。
And in a way that is never entirely explained, Leda that night sleeps both with Tyndareus and with Zeus in the form of a swan. So she has quite an active night. Very busy night. And this is why when she gives birth to quadruplets, you have two mortal and two immortal children hatching out of the eggs that she lays. And the Spartans are actually very proud of this story. And so Pausanias, who is a Greek writing in the second century AD, he's basically kind of writing
以一种从未完全解释清楚的方式，丽达那天晚上既与廷达瑞俄斯同床，也与化身为天鹅的宙斯同床。所以她那一晚相当活跃。非常忙碌的一晚。这就是为什么当她生下四胞胎时，会有两个凡人和两个不朽的孩子从她产下的蛋中孵化出来。斯巴达人实际上对这个故事感到非常自豪。所以保萨尼阿斯，一位公元二世纪的希腊作家，他基本上是在写
a travel guide to Greece. And he says that in Sparta, you can see the shell of the egg, and it's preserved in a temple on the Acropolis in Sparta. So his advice to travellers to Sparta, Tom, was a thousand times better than your advice to me when I went to Sparta and you recommended that I go to a place that when I googled it, it said notorious hangout for down and out thieves, drug addicts and so on. Well, we'll be coming to that advice because of course, so Helen grows up and Spartan girls are notorious in the Greek world for being educated. They're the only girls who get a state education in Greece. And there's a big focus on kind of sport and athletics
一本希腊旅游指南。他说在斯巴达，你可以看到蛋壳，它保存在斯巴达卫城的一座神庙里。所以汤姆，你给去斯巴达的游客的建议，比我上次去斯巴达时你给我的建议好上一千倍，当时你推荐我去一个地方，我谷歌了一下，上面说那是流浪汉、小偷、瘾君子等人的臭名昭著的聚集地。好吧，我们会谈到那个建议，因为当然，海伦长大了，斯巴达女孩在希腊世界以受过教育而闻名。她们是希腊唯一接受国家教育的女孩。而且非常注重体育和竞技
and Euripides, who is an Athenian who writes famous tragedies in the fifth century BC. He has a description of Helen doing gym work with the other girls in Sparta, her thighs naked exposed by the lifting of her skimpy tunic, sharing with boys the running track and the gymnasium. There's a hell of a lot of thighs in this podcast so far, Tom. Well, you know, I've said that Greek myths are often seen as being suitable for children. They are absolutely not. They are shocking.
欧里庇得斯，一位在公元前五世纪创作著名悲剧的雅典人。他描述了海伦在斯巴达和其他女孩一起做体操，她的大腿裸露在外，因为撩起了短小的束腰外衣，与男孩们共用跑道和体育馆。汤姆，到目前为止，这个播客里有太多关于大腿的内容了。好吧，你知道，我说过希腊神话通常被认为适合儿童。它们绝对不适合。它们令人震惊。
Yeah. And there are repeated instances, for instance, of rape. And this is what happens with Helen. She is out with the girls, practicing her sport. Probably, Dominic, tradition says, at the site of the temple of Artemis Orthia, which was the temple that I sent you to. And that's the place. Well, I didn't go. We went to a restaurant instead. Anyway, go on. Well, so it's an ill-omened place because this is where Helen, she's 12 years old. So 12 is traditionally the age at which girls become available to be married. So she is on the cusp of being nubile. And she is spotted by
是的。而且有反复出现的例子，例如强奸。这就是海伦身上发生的事情。她和女孩们出去练习运动。多米尼克，传统说法可能是在阿尔忒弥斯·奥尔提亚神庙遗址，那是我让你去的神庙。就是那个地方。好吧，我没去。我们去了一家餐馆。总之，继续。好吧，这是一个不祥之地，因为海伦就是在这里，她当时12岁。所以12岁在传统上是女孩可以结婚的年龄。所以她正处于青春期的边缘。她被
a Greek hero who's very famous, who probably most people who've read any book on the Greek myths will have heard of. And this is Theseus, the Athenian hero who kills the Minotaur on Crete. And in the books about Theseus that I read when I was a child, this episode was not mentioned. But Theseus, he's passing the temple of Artemis Orthia, and he sees the 12-year-old Helen, and he is transfixed. She is the most beautiful thing he has ever seen. And so he abducts her. He takes her back to Attica, the land around Athens. He imprisons her on the Acropolis of a town there called Aphidna, and he appoints his mother, Ithra, to look after the young Helen. And then he goes off to try and abduct and rape Persephone, who is the queen of the dead, the wife of Hades, as you do. And while he is down
一位非常著名的希腊英雄发现了，大多数读过希腊神话书籍的人可能都听说过。这就是忒修斯，在克里特岛杀死弥诺陶洛斯的雅典英雄。在我小时候读过的关于忒修斯的书中，没有提到这一集。但是忒修斯，他经过阿尔忒弥斯·奥尔提亚神庙，看到了12岁的海伦，他被惊呆了。她是他见过的最美丽的东西。于是他绑架了她。他把她带回了阿提卡，即雅典周围的土地。他把她囚禁在当地一个叫阿菲德纳的小镇的卫城上，并指派他的母亲埃特拉照顾年轻的海伦。然后他去试图绑架和强奸冥后珀耳塞福涅，也就是哈迪斯的妻子，就像你做的那样。当他在
in the underworld, he ends up getting stuck to a seat and has to be rescued in the long run by hercules yeah but castor and pollux come and rescue their sister and they sack a fidna and they take aithra to serve helen as her maid which is what will then happen so a question about this that you said this was euripides obviously theseus is associated with athens she's from sparta yeah how much does that story reflect the political culture of the wars, the rivalry between Athens and Sparta? So it's a story of Athenians sacking Sparta or something, isn't it? That's what is ultimately behind this fantasy. The way that Euripides frames it in the depths of the Peloponnesian war, this terrible conflict between Athens and Sparta is definitely
冥界时，他最终被困在座位上，不得不由赫拉克勒斯最终救出。是的，但卡斯托耳和波吕丢刻斯来救他们的妹妹，他们洗劫了阿菲德纳，并带走了埃特拉去侍奉海伦，这就是后来发生的事情。所以关于这一点有一个问题，你说这是欧里庇得斯写的，显然忒修斯与雅典有关，她来自斯巴达。是的，那个故事在多大程度上反映了战争的政治文化，即雅典和斯巴达之间的竞争？所以这是一个雅典人洗劫斯巴达之类的故事，不是吗？这就是这个幻想背后的最终原因。欧里庇得斯在伯罗奔尼撒战争的深处，在雅典和斯巴达之间这场可怕的冲突中构建它的方式，绝对是
drawing on that. But the roots of the story are much older. Okay. And this is the fascination of it is that elements of the story can just be reworked and reworked by Greeks at various points and with various perspectives. But the kind of the core of the story does genuinely seem to be very ancient. Okay. And running throughout it is this idea that Helen's beauty drives men mad. And so people may wonder, well, what did she look like? So Bethany Hughes has written a wonderful book on Helen of Troy, both as myth and the possible history that might lie behind her. She observes that the wonderful irony about the most beautiful woman in the world is that she is faceless. But there are kind of various traditional attributes of her beauty that
借鉴了这一点。但这个故事的根源要古老得多。好的。这正是它的迷人之处，故事的元素可以被希腊人在不同的时间点和不同的视角下不断地重新加工。但故事的核心似乎确实非常古老。好的。贯穿其中的是海伦的美貌让男人疯狂的想法。所以人们可能会想，她长什么样？贝瑟尼·休斯写了一本关于特洛伊海伦的精彩著作，既是神话，也是她背后可能存在的历史。她观察到，关于世界上最美丽的女人，最美妙的讽刺是她没有面孔。但关于她的美貌，有各种各样的传统属性
are described repeatedly. So one is that she has white skin like the shell that she hatched from. Yeah. So she is always described as kind of blindingly white. She is golden haired. Her hair is described as xanthus. So that is a color that is associated with the divine. Yeah. Her hair is more beautiful than any other woman's. And she has perfect milky white breasts. And the evidence for this is adduced by Pliny the Elder, the great Roman encyclopedist, who records that in Rhodes, in a temple of Athena, there is a goblet. And it is said to have been cast to correspond to the dimensions
被反复描述。其中之一是她有着像她孵化出来的蛋壳一样洁白的皮肤。是的，所以她总是被描述为那种耀眼的白色。她有着金色的头发。她的头发被描述为“xanthus”（金黄色）。这是一种与神性相关的颜色。是的。她的头发比任何其他女性的都要美丽。她有着完美如牛奶般洁白的乳房。老普林尼，那位伟大的罗马百科全书编纂者，提供了这一证据，他记录道，在罗德岛雅典娜神庙里有一个高脚杯。据说它是按照海伦乳房的尺寸铸造的。
of one of Helen's breasts. And people go and admire it and say, yes, that is absolutely perfect. So just at this stage, I know you'll probably come to this in the second half, so we don't need to get into the weeds of the discussion right away. But obviously so far, everything that has been written and indeed presumably the goblet and so on and so forth has been made by men. And lots of people listening to this will be thinking this is just a kind of male fantasy this is the male gaze run riot tom you know this is just a total male sexist fantasy so we should come to the discussion of that probably later on i guess we will and there is uh one very famous female greek writer who does write about helen and we'll come to her in due course. But you're right. I mean, she is driving men mad. And the fact that she's been abducted and raped as a girl does not put
人们去欣赏它并说，是的，那绝对是完美的。所以就在这个阶段，我知道你可能在下半部分会讲到，所以我们不需要马上陷入讨论的泥潭。但显然到目前为止，所有写下的东西，甚至包括那个高脚杯等等，都是男人制造的。很多听众会认为这只是一种男性幻想，这是男性凝视的泛滥，汤姆，你知道，这完全是一个男性沙文主义的幻想，所以我们可能稍后再讨论这个问题，我想我们会讨论的。而且确实有一位非常著名的希腊女作家写过海伦，我们以后会讲到她。但你是对的。我的意思是，她让男人们疯狂。而且她作为一个女孩被绑架和强奸的事实并没有让
off her suitors, quite the opposite. So Tyndareus basically says, no, I don't know what to do about this. Every man in Greece, every powerful king in Greece wants her. What am I going to do? And Odysseus, the most cunning and clever of the Greek heroes, comes up with this wheeze. And he says, well, get all the heroes to swear an oath that if any one of them abducts her, everyone else will team together and get Helen back. And Tyndareus thinks, yeah, that's a brilliant idea. I'll do that. And Odysseus' reward for this is that he gets as his wife, Helen's cousin, Penelope, who in the epics will serve as a model of the faithful wife. You know, she's sensible, she's wise,
她的追求者们退缩，恰恰相反。所以廷达瑞俄斯基本上说，不，我不知道该怎么办。希腊的每一个男人，希腊的每一位强大的国王都想要她。我该怎么办？而奥德修斯，希腊英雄中最狡猾、最聪明的一位，想出了这个主意。他说，好吧，让所有的英雄都发誓，如果他们中的任何一个人绑架了她，其他人都会联合起来把海伦夺回来。廷达瑞俄斯心想，是的，这是个绝妙的主意。我会这么做的。而奥德修斯因此得到的奖励是，他娶了海伦的表妹佩涅洛佩为妻，她在史诗中将成为忠贞妻子的典范。你知道，她通情达理，她很明智，
and in a way kind of a much better wife than Helen. But obviously everyone wants Helen. And the person who ends up getting her is a guy called Menelaus. He's useless, totally useless in all the stories. I mean, he's certainly not on a level with Helen. So for starters, he's a younger on a level with Helen. So for starters, he's a younger brother. Dominic, you and I are both elder brothers, so we approve of the Greek tradition that says the elder brother is generally more admirable. Some even say that
而且在某种程度上，她比海伦要好得多。但显然每个人都想要海伦。最终得到她的人是一个叫墨涅拉俄斯的人。他在所有的故事里都很没用，完全没用。我的意思是，他肯定不在海伦的水平上。所以首先，他是一个弟弟。多米尼克，你和我都是哥哥，所以我们赞同希腊的传统，即哥哥通常更令人钦佩。有些人甚至说
Menelaus' elder brother, who is Agamemnon, the man who will marry Helen's sister Clytemnestra, that he does the wooing for Menelaus. And Menelaus at this point does not have a palace for reasons that we'll come to later. So he moves into Tyndareus' palace and in due course inherits it and Helen's treasure and gold. So he is pretty much completely defined by Helen. And this is emasculating for a Greek king. He is behaving like the bride moving into the person he's marrying home. So basically his rank depends on being married to Helen. And this is a cause of embarrassment. And they have a daughter, but they have no son. And I think there's generally a sense that Helen is too beautiful to have children. She stays kind of naturally beautiful throughout. And the experience of motherhood is not something that ages her,
墨涅拉俄斯的哥哥，也就是阿伽门农，那个将要娶海伦的姐姐克吕泰涅斯特拉的人，是他替墨涅拉俄斯求婚的。而墨涅拉俄斯此时还没有宫殿，原因我们稍后再说。所以他搬进了廷达瑞俄斯的宫殿，并最终继承了它以及海伦的财宝和黄金。所以他几乎完全被海伦定义了。这对一位希腊国王来说是去势的。他的行为就像是搬进妻子家里的新郎。所以基本上他的地位取决于是否娶了海伦。这令人尴尬。他们有一个女儿，但没有儿子。我认为人们普遍认为海伦太美了，以至于无法生育。她始终保持着那种自然的魅力。而为人母的经历并不会让她变老，
which presumably is why she doesn't have lots of children. Anyway, so they're all hanging out. Menelaus and Helen and their daughter Hermione are in Sparta when who should turn up but a prince from Troy, a city on the other side of the Aegean. Paris. Yes, called Paris. And Paris has come to Sparta sent by Aphrodite, the goddess of love, because we talked about how the Greeks loved a beauty contest and even the goddesses occasionally like a beauty contest. And a golden apple has been thrown into a banquet with the praise to the fairest and three goddesses, Hera, the queen of the gods, Athena, the goddess of wisdom, Aphrodite, the goddess of beauty and love. So you think actually, I mean, she was always going to win a beauty contest.
这大概就是她没有生很多孩子的原因。总之，他们都在一起。墨涅拉俄斯、海伦和他们的女儿赫耳弥俄涅在斯巴达时，谁出现了呢？一位来自特洛伊的王子，一座位于爱琴海另一侧的城市。帕里斯。是的，叫帕里斯。帕里斯来到斯巴达是受爱神阿佛洛狄忒的派遣，因为我们谈到过希腊人多么喜欢选美比赛，甚至女神们偶尔也喜欢选美。一个金苹果被扔进了一场宴会，上面写着“献给最美者”，三位女神，赫拉，众神之后，雅典娜，智慧女神，阿佛洛狄忒，美与爱之女神。所以你实际上会想，我的意思是，她总是会赢得选美比赛的。
But anyway, Paris has been appointed to judge between them. He has chosen Aphrodite. And so Aphrodite in return has promised him the most beautiful woman in the world. And this is why Paris has arrived. And Paris is much better suited to Helen than Menelaus is, because if Sparta is famous among the Greeks as the home of the most beautiful women, Troy is famous for the beauty of its men. So Ganymede, the cupbearer of Zeus, is a Trojan.
但无论如何，帕里斯被指定在她们之间做出评判。他选择了阿佛洛狄忒。作为回报，阿佛洛狄忒承诺给他世界上最美丽的女人。这就是帕里斯到达的原因。帕里斯比墨涅拉俄斯更适合海伦，因为如果斯巴达在希腊人中以拥有最美丽的女性而闻名，那么特洛伊则以其男性的美貌而闻名。所以伽倪墨得，宙斯的斟酒人，就是个特洛伊人。
And so Paris is, he has a slightly kind of feminine quality to his, his handsomeness. He's a kind of feline figure, isn't he, Paris? Yes, he's feline. Yes, absolutely. And he is stalking Helen and Menelaus makes it very easy for him because his grandfather has died in Crete. And so he goes away and Helen and Menelaus are left alone in Sparta. And Paris sets off with her. Now, the question is, does Helen go willingly or not?
所以帕里斯，他的英俊带有一种略微女性化的特质。他是一个猫科动物般的人物，不是吗，帕里斯？是的，他是猫科动物。是的，绝对是。他在跟踪海伦，而墨涅拉俄斯让他变得非常容易，因为他的祖父在克里特岛去世了。所以他离开了，海伦和墨涅拉俄斯被单独留在斯巴达。帕里斯带着她出发了。现在的问题是，海伦是自愿走的吗？
So is this another story of rape? And a lot of contemporary renderings of the story say that it is. But it has to be said that basically the ancients are pretty unanimous. Helen chooses to go. And more than that, she actually dazzles Paris. She takes her treasure with her. When she goes, in all the epics, the tragedies, all the accounts, she is never described as Paris's concubine or whore or slave. She's always his wife. So she maintains her status and her rank and her dignity, but at the cost of being an adulteress. So she is going.
所以这是另一个关于强奸的故事吗？许多当代对这个故事的演绎都说是。但必须说，基本上古人们相当一致。海伦选择了离开。不仅如此，她实际上让帕里斯眼花缭乱。她带着她的财宝一起走了。当她离开时，在所有的史诗、悲剧和记载中，她从未被描述为帕里斯的妾、妓女或奴隶。她始终是他的妻子。所以她保持了她的地位、等级和尊严，但代价是成为一名通奸者。所以她是主动离开的。
And you asked about, has a woman written about Troy? Sappho, who is a famous lyric poet, we've only had fragments of her poetry, but she was celebrated as the 10th muse. She wrote, for she that far surpassed all mortals in beauty, Helen, her most noble husband deserted and went sailing to Troy with never a thought for her daughter and dear parents. So Sappho is seizing on the things that a woman in Greek culture should probably be doing, looking after her parents, looking after her children, looking after her husband. Helen, not doing any of that. She has a kind of what in Greek terms is a sense of masculine autonomy. And she goes off with Paris and they have their first night together on a rocky island
你问过，有没有女性写过特洛伊？萨福，一位著名的抒情诗人，我们只得到了她诗歌的残篇，但她被誉为第十位缪斯。她写道：“因为她那远超凡人的美貌，海伦，抛弃了她最高贵的丈夫，航行前往特洛伊，从未想过她的女儿和亲爱的父母。”所以萨福抓住了希腊文化中女性应该做的事情，照顾父母，照顾孩子，照顾丈夫。海伦，这些都没做。她有一种希腊语境下的“男性自主感”。她和帕里斯一起走了，他们在岩石岛上度过了他们的第一夜，
called Cranae, which is just off the mainland of Sparta. And in the Iliad, Homer's great epic. So kind of almost nine years later, Paris still remembers that night as something remarkable and extraordinary. And he takes her off to Troy and all the Trojans are besotted with her as well. So that when Menelaus and Odysseus come to ask for Helen back, all the Trojans say, no, we're not going to give her back. Even though they know that the Greeks have sworn this oath, that they will get together
那个岛叫克拉纳厄，就在斯巴达大陆附近。在荷马的伟大史诗《伊利亚特》中。所以大约九年后，帕里斯仍然记得那个夜晚是多么非凡和特别。他把她带到了特洛伊，所有的特洛伊人也都被她迷住了。所以当墨涅拉俄斯和奥德修斯来要求带回海伦时，所有的特洛伊人都说，不，我们不会把她还回去。即使他们知道希腊人已经发过誓，他们会联合起来
and come and get her, the Trojans won't do it. They're so dazzled, like Paris was, by her beauty. Absolutely. And so there's a philosopher called Socrates, an Athenian in the fourth century, who says that this is why the Trojan War is the greatest and most terrible conflict ever fought. So he says, it is clear how both sides felt about it, the Trojans as well as the Greeks. For although there had been many causes of contention between them before, none of these had disturbed their peace.
过来把她带走，特洛伊人也不会这么做。他们像帕里斯一样，被她的美貌迷住了。绝对是。所以有一位哲学家叫苏格拉底，一位公元前四世纪的雅典人，他说这就是为什么特洛伊战争是有史以来最伟大、最可怕的冲突。所以他说，双方对此的感受显而易见，特洛伊人也和希腊人一样。因为尽管他们之前有很多争端，但没有一个扰乱了他们的和平。
Whereas over Helen, they fought the greatest of wars, greatest not only for the scale of the passion involved, but also for how long it lasted and the sheer scale of the violence it unleashed. And this violence is made worse by the fact that the gods too end up fighting over Helen. So in the Trojan War, Aphrodite is on one side, the side of Paris and the Trojans, and Athena and Hera are on the Greek side because they hate Paris. But basically they're fighting over Helen. And Socrates says the whole universe goes mad. And he draws this conclusion that beauty by nature rules over strength. So you were saying this is a male fantasy, but essentially what Socrates is doing there is saying the power
然而为了海伦，他们打了一场最伟大的战争，最伟大不仅是因为涉及的激情规模，还因为战争持续的时间以及它所引发的暴力规模。而这种暴力因为众神最终也为了海伦而战而变得更加糟糕。所以在特洛伊战争中，阿佛洛狄忒站在一边，即帕里斯和特洛伊人的一边，而雅典娜和赫拉站在希腊一边，因为她们讨厌帕里斯。但基本上她们是在为海伦而战。苏格拉底说整个宇宙都疯了。他得出了这样一个结论：美貌天生统治着力量。所以你刚才说这是男性幻想，但苏格拉底本质上是在说，
of Helen's beauty is greater than the strength of all the men who came to fight her. So if you go to Homer's epic, the Iliad, obviously most of the action, or indeed almost all of the action revolves around the men, Achilles, Hector, Patroclus, Odysseus, and so on and so forth. Does Helen have a, she does have a role in the Trojan war story, doesn't she? Because Paris is killed yeah is he killed by an arrow have I got that right
海伦美貌的力量大于所有为她而战的男人的力量。所以如果你去看荷马的史诗《伊利亚特》，显然大部分行动，或者说几乎所有的行动都围绕着男人，阿喀琉斯、赫克托耳、帕特罗克洛斯、奥德修斯等等。海伦在特洛伊战争的故事中有一个角色，不是吗？因为帕里斯被杀了，是的，他是被箭射死的吗？我没记错吧？
that's right and then she marries somebody else Di Phobos he's a lucky man because you know he gets the most beautiful woman
没错，然后她嫁给了别人，得伊福玻斯。他是个幸运的人，因为你知道，他得到了最美丽的女人。
well he's not a lucky man actually I mean so he is the fourth of Helen's husbands yeah he's a brother of Paris very good warrior
嗯，他其实不是个幸运的人。我的意思是，他是海伦的第四任丈夫，是的，他是帕里斯的兄弟，一位非常优秀的战士。
hold on the fourth oh because Theseus I forgot about Theseus yeah so there's Theseus, I forgot about Theseus. Yeah, so there's Theseus as well. Yeah. So actually, he's not lucky because Helen completely stiffs him over. And Helen is behaving very badly towards the end of the Trojan War. So the famous story of the Trojan horse, all the Greeks have hidden themselves inside the
等等，第四任？哦，因为忒修斯，我忘了忒修斯了。是的，所以还有忒修斯。是的，所以实际上，他并不幸运，因为海伦完全把他耍了。海伦在特洛伊战争末期的表现非常糟糕。所以那个著名的特洛伊木马故事，所有的希腊人都把自己藏在
horse and the horse gets wheeled into Troy. Helen comes down to the horse and she walks around the horse and she mimics the wives of the Greek heroes calling out to them. And the heroes have been away by this point for 10 years. And Menelaus, of course, hears Helen's own voice, but two other heroes hear it and they are about to call out. And Odysseus knows what is happening and he throttles one of the heroes to stop him from calling out. Like Custer with his dogs before one of those massacres. Very similar. Yeah, not a parallel that I think has ever been made before, but that's what the podcast is all about. And in due course, Menelaus will blame this not on Helen
木马里，木马被推进了特洛伊。海伦走到木马前，她绕着木马走，模仿希腊英雄妻子的声音呼唤他们。而英雄们此时已经离开家10年了。墨涅拉俄斯当然听到了海伦自己的声音，但另外两名英雄也听到了，他们正要回应。奥德修斯知道发生了什么，他勒住其中一名英雄的脖子，阻止他回应。就像卡斯特在屠杀前对待他的狗一样。非常相似。是的，我不认为有人做过这种类比，但这正是这个播客的意义所在。最终，墨涅拉俄斯不会把这归咎于海伦
herself, but on Aphrodite, that Aphrodite has possessed her. And the ability to mimic is traditionally one of Aphrodite's attributes. But I think Helen is very deceptive. She is very manipulative. And we might see that again as kind of misogynist stereotyping. It isn't really. It's giving her the attributes of a god. This is what gods do. Gods do deceive. Just on that question, is she is she divine i mean she's half divine right she is half divine and we'll come to that the question of you know is she mortal is she divine is she both i mean we'll come to that yeah but just sticking to the topic of how helen behaves badly even as she's trying to and the stories are contradictory on the one hand she is trying to save troy by getting the heroes to come out of the horse. But on the other hand, she wants her husband dead and all the Trojans dead. So she has hidden Deiphobus' sword. And the moment she sees
本人，而是归咎于阿佛洛狄忒，说是阿佛洛狄忒附身了她。而模仿的能力传统上是阿佛洛狄忒的属性之一。但我认为海伦非常善于欺骗。她非常有操纵性。我们可能会再次将其视为某种厌女症的刻板印象。其实不然。这是赋予她神的能力。这就是神所做的。神确实会欺骗。关于那个问题，她是神吗？我的意思是她是半神，对吧？她是半神，我们会谈到这个问题，关于她是凡人还是神，还是两者皆是，我的意思是我们会谈到这一点。是的，但就海伦表现糟糕的话题而言，即使在她试图……而且故事是矛盾的，一方面她试图通过让英雄们从木马里出来来拯救特洛伊。但另一方面，她希望她的丈夫死，所有的特洛伊人都死。所以她藏起了得伊福玻斯的剑。当她看到
the Greeks come out, she says, oh, he's in there, go and kill him. So she seems to have decided by this point that she wants to go back with Menelaus. Now you may think, I mean, Menelaus has become the most notorious cookhold in world mythology. Anden by his lights is responsible for the deaths of thousands and thousands of people yeah so what's he going to do and all the sources imply that he's aiming to kill her and there are vases it shows menelaus coming in with his sword upraised it happens in tragedies so euripides again, who's obsessed by Helen and is always kind of giving various portraits of her. In one of his plays, The Trojan Women, which is kind of completely bleak account of what happens to the women after the sack of Troy, their enslavement,
希腊人出来时，她说，哦，他在那儿，去杀了他。所以她似乎在这一点上已经决定她想和墨涅拉俄斯一起回去。现在你可能会想，我的意思是，墨涅拉俄斯已经成为世界神话中最臭名昭著的戴绿帽者。而且按照他的观点，他要为成千上万人的死亡负责。是的，那他打算怎么办？所有的来源都暗示他打算杀了她，而且有花瓶画显示墨涅拉俄斯举着剑走进来。这发生在悲剧里，所以欧里庇得斯，他再次痴迷于海伦，总是给出她的各种画像。在他的一部剧作《特洛伊妇女》中，这是一部关于特洛伊陷落后妇女遭遇的完全凄凉的描述，她们的奴役，
their rape. Menelaus is shown coming in, Helen confronts him, and it's very rare that Helen justifies herself. But basically her response to Menelaus is to say, it was your fault. You should have looked after me better. And then she kind of ends by calling him an idiot. And you'd think this isn't a great way to stop your husband from killing you. But Menelaus is transfixed by her. And you will see on vases that often Helen is shown adjusting her veil. And it's unclear whether she's covering her beautiful face or whether she is unveiling her hair. But in either way, Menelaus drops his sword. In Lysistrata, which is the great comedy by Aristophanes, women kind of trying to stop the Peloponnesian war, there's a description
她们的强奸。墨涅拉俄斯被展示走进来，海伦与他对峙，海伦很少为自己辩护。但基本上她对墨涅拉俄斯的回答是说，那是你的错。你应该更好地照顾我。然后她以称他为白痴结束。你会认为这不是阻止你丈夫杀你的好方法。但墨涅拉俄斯被她迷住了。你会看到花瓶上经常显示海伦在调整她的面纱。不清楚她是想遮住她美丽的脸，还是在揭开她的头发。但无论哪种方式，墨涅拉俄斯都放下了他的剑。在阿里斯托芬的伟大喜剧《利西翠妲》中，妇女们试图阻止伯罗奔尼撒战争，里面有一段描述
of Helen's beauty. When Menelaus caught a glimpse of Helen's breasts, naked as they were, then he dropped his sword. So once again, you have the idea that women have this through their sexuality. They have this necromantic power over men, or at least she does. Helen does, because all the other women, they either get killed or enslaved. Helen doesn't. Helen is kept by Menelaus as his queen. They go back to Sparta in the Odyssey, which is the sequel to the Iliad, describes the wanderings of Odysseus for another 10 years. Odysseus' son Telemachus goes to Sparta to ask for help finding his father, and is hosted by Menelaus and Helen. Helen has this kind of potion, which you drink it,
海伦的美貌。当墨涅拉俄斯瞥见海伦赤裸的乳房时，他放下了剑。所以再一次，你有了这种想法，即女性通过她们的性能力拥有这种力量。她们对男人拥有这种死灵法术般的力量，或者至少她有。海伦有，因为所有其他的女性，她们要么被杀，要么被奴役。海伦没有。海伦被墨涅拉俄斯留作他的王后。他们在《奥德赛》中回到斯巴达，这是《伊利亚特》的续集，描述了奥德修斯又10年的流浪。奥德修斯的儿子特勒马科斯去斯巴达寻求帮助寻找他的父亲，并受到墨涅拉俄斯和海伦的款待。海伦有这种药水，你喝了它，
and it eases pain and grief. People have said, maybe this is opium or something, but I think that's reductive. I think it's another expression of Helen's more than human powers that just as she has caused the trauma of bereavement and grief, so fleetingly she has the power to heal it. She can soothe your injured feelings or whatever. Yeah. And what happens to Helen, there are again, various accounts. So Pausanias, this gazetteer, he says that there's a temple in Rhodes again, that Helen got seized by the maids of a woman who had died at Troy and they hang Helen from a tree. But this is very unusual and very late. It is very rare for the death of Helen to be described. So she's hated, she's cursed, she's insulted. But again and again, when people
它能减轻痛苦和悲伤。人们说，也许这是鸦片之类的东西，但我认为这太简化了。我认为这是海伦超越人类力量的另一种表现，就像她引起了丧亲和悲伤的创伤一样，她也短暂地拥有治愈它的力量。她可以抚慰你受伤的情绪等等。是的。海伦后来怎么样了？同样有各种各样的说法。所以保萨尼阿斯，这位地理学家，他说在罗德岛又有一座神庙，海伦被一个在特洛伊死去的妇女的侍女们抓住，她们把海伦吊在树上。但这非常罕见且非常晚。海伦的死亡被描述是非常罕见的。所以她被憎恨，被诅咒，被侮辱。但一次又一次，当人们
try to kill her, they just find they can't. She's too beautiful. All the gods intervene. So again, Euripides in another play, he describes how someone has cornered her, is trying to kill her, and then Helen just vanishes. She's been removed by the gods. They're kind of looking after her. And there is this idea, which is very ancient, that Helen has actually gone to the Elysian fields, so like Russell Crowe. So in the Odyssey, Menelaus is told that if he sticks with Helen, then he will go to the Elysian fields well. And he's told all this is because you are Helen's husband and ranked by the gods as
试图杀死她，他们却发现自己做不到。她太美了。所有的神都介入了。所以，欧里庇得斯在另一部戏剧中再次描述了有人如何将她逼入绝境，试图杀死她，然后海伦就消失了。她被众神带走了。他们某种程度上在照顾她。而且有一个非常古老的观点，认为海伦实际上去了极乐世界，就像罗素·克劳那样。所以在《奥德赛》中，墨涅拉俄斯被告知，如果他坚持和海伦在一起，那么他也会去极乐世界。他被告知这一切都是因为你是海伦的丈夫，被众神排在
Zeus's son-in-law. And does he? Yeah, he does, according to tradition. He's done very well for such a useless person. Right, but Greek mythology being Greek mythology, there is an alternative tradition, which again is in Pausanias, the gazetteer. And he says that Helen ends up married to Achilles, the great warrior who has actually died in the Trojan War.
宙斯的女婿之列。他真的去了吗？是的，根据传统，他去了。对于一个如此无用的人来说，他做得非常好了。没错，但希腊神话毕竟是希腊神话，还有另一种传统，同样记载在地理学家保萨尼阿斯的著作中。他说海伦最终嫁给了阿喀琉斯，那位在特洛伊战争中实际上已经阵亡的伟大战士。
And he says that in the Black Sea, opposite the mouth of the Danube, there is an island called Leuke, which means the White Island, and that this is where Achilles lives. And Helen is there, and Helen is his wife. So Achilles is Helen's fifth husband. And in the Roman period, this account is supplemented by a whole load of writers. And have you read Roberto collasso's marriage of caberson harmony i haven't but i'm aware of it it's wonderful weird haunting account of the greek myths yeah and he has a brilliant rendering of all these various greek writings so i'll just read it on leaving the danube for the open sea sailors must pass by luke the white island they
他说在黑海，多瑙河口对面，有一个岛叫琉克，意思是白岛，这就是阿喀琉斯居住的地方。海伦也在那里，她是他的妻子。所以阿喀琉斯是海伦的第五任丈夫。在罗马时期，这一说法得到了大量作家的补充。你读过罗伯托·卡拉索的《卡德摩斯与哈耳摩尼亚的婚礼》吗？我没读过，但我知道它。这是一部关于希腊神话的精彩、怪诞且令人难忘的著作。是的，他有对所有这些各种希腊著作的精彩演绎，所以我读一下：离开多瑙河前往公海时，水手们必须经过白岛琉克，他们
see a coastline of dunes rocks rocks and woods. It's an island for castaways and people who want to offer up a sacrifice. No one has ever dared stay there after sundown and no woman has ever trod at sandy beaches. The only building on the island is a temple with two statues, Achilles and Helen. The temple guards are seagulls. Every morning they wet their wings in the sea and sprinkle water on the stones. Achilles lives on the island as Helen's fifth husband. Some have seen him appear in the dazzling armor that once blinded Homer with its brilliance. At night, they chant the poetry of Homer in high, clear voices. So that's amazing.
看到的是一片沙丘、岩石和树木的海岸线。这是一个供遇难者和想要献祭的人居住的岛屿。从来没有人敢在日落后留在那里，也从来没有女人踏上过那里的沙滩。岛上唯一的建筑是一座有两尊雕像的寺庙，分别是阿喀琉斯和海伦。寺庙的守护者是海鸥。每天早上，它们都会在海里打湿翅膀，然后把水洒在石头上。阿喀琉斯作为海伦的第五任丈夫住在岛上。有些人曾看到他穿着那件曾经以光芒刺瞎荷马双眼的耀眼盔甲出现。晚上，他们用高亢、清脆的声音吟诵荷马的诗歌。这太神奇了。
I mean, Achilles and Helen are chanting poetry written about themselves. Sometimes when boats drop anchor off the beach, the sailors hear a drumming of horses hooves the clashing of weapons and the cries of warriors so this idea of war as something eternal and what makes this passage which was written before the russian invasion of ukraine all the more haunting is that the white island is the island that is also called Snake Island. So that was the first day of the war. The Russians attacked, didn't they? And there was a Ukrainian little garrison. And the Russians famously are supposed to have said, you know, surrender or face attack or whatever.
我的意思是，阿喀琉斯和海伦在吟诵关于他们自己的诗歌。有时当船只在海滩外抛锚时，水手们会听到马蹄的敲击声、武器的碰撞声和战士们的呐喊声。所以这种将战争视为永恒的想法，以及让这段写于俄罗斯入侵乌克兰之前的文字变得更加令人难忘的原因是，白岛就是那个也被称为蛇岛的岛屿。所以那是战争的第一天。俄罗斯人发动了攻击，不是吗？那里有一个小小的乌克兰驻军。据说俄罗斯人当时很有名地说，你知道，投降或者面临攻击之类的。
And the border guard said, Russian warship, go F yourself. And everyone said, what a tremendous thing this is. Hurrah for Ukraine, all that sort of stuff. And it's actually a very Homeric scene, Tom. It is a Homeric scene and it happened on a Homeric place where Achilles and Helen still live to this day. So on that note, perhaps we should take a break. Right.
边防警卫说，俄罗斯军舰，去你的吧。每个人都说，这真是太了不起了。乌克兰万岁，诸如此类的话。这实际上是一个非常荷马式的场景，汤姆。这确实是一个荷马式的场景，而且它发生在一个荷马式的地方，阿喀琉斯和海伦至今仍住在那里。所以说到这里，也许我们应该休息一下。好的。
So what we should do after the break is we should find out what on earth is going on behind all these stories. Where do they come from? Was there a real helen and if there wasn't what are the greeks trying to do by creating this kind of literary mythological figure so we'll see you after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
所以休息之后我们应该做的是，找出这些故事背后到底发生了什么。它们从哪里来？真的有海伦吗？如果没有，希腊人通过创造这种文学神话人物想要做什么？所以我们休息后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. So, the leading men of troy sat upon the tower and they as they saw helen approaching in undertone spoke winged words to one another no blame that the trojans and strong grieved greeks have suffered so long on account of such a woman terribly does she seem like the immortal goddesses to look on that was top writer homer in the iliad and there you have the sense that leading men of troy sitting on the task seeing helen approaching the sense of the desire the kind of yearning the obsession because of her
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。所以，特洛伊的领袖们坐在塔楼上，当他们看到海伦走近时，低声细语，对彼此说了带翼的话：特洛伊人和强大的希腊人因为这样一个女人而遭受了这么久的苦难，这并不奇怪。她看起来确实非常像不朽的女神。那是顶级作家荷马在《伊利亚特》中写的，在那里你感受到了特洛伊领袖们坐在塔上看到海伦走近的感觉，那种渴望，那种向往，那种因为她而产生的痴迷
dazzling beauty but also you know terribly does she seem like the immortal goddess is to look on. The sense that she's frightening, that she is, as we said in the first half, fateful and fatal. And it's not surprising that the elders of Troy, when they see her coming, think to themselves, oh, you know, we're for it now.
耀眼的美丽，但也你知道，她看起来确实非常像不朽的女神。那种她令人恐惧的感觉，正如我们在前半部分所说，她是命中注定的，也是致命的。特洛伊的长老们看到她走来时，心里想，哦，你知道，我们这次完了，这并不奇怪。
Because with great beauty comes great disaster. Yeah. And they actually say we should send her back. Yeah. And then they say, oh, no, let's not. Priam not priam the king of troy says no let's keep her again though if you to pick up the theme from the first half again you could say this is how men have often seen women's sexuality as both something very desirable and something to be feared couldn't you tom yeah i guess so and helen as the most beautiful of women, obviously kind of raises that to a pitch. And I think it has to be something that is overwhelmingly powerful for the whole
因为巨大的美丽伴随着巨大的灾难。是的。他们实际上说我们应该把她送回去。是的。然后他们说，哦，不，别这样。普里阿摩斯，特洛伊国王，说不，让我们留下她。不过，如果你想再次拾起前半部分的主题，你可以说这就是男人经常看待女性性欲的方式，既是非常令人向往的，也是令人恐惧的，不是吗，汤姆？是的，我想是这样。海伦作为最美丽的女性，显然把这种感觉提升到了一个高度。我认为这必须是极其强大的，整个
story of the Trojan War to make sense. Because the question is, of course, are the Greeks justified? Are the Trojans justified in fighting over her? And I think that that is also a part of what makes Helen so interesting to various Greek writers over the sweep of Greek history, is that she provides opportunities for all kinds of writers from different backgrounds and writing in different styles. She gives the material. So we mentioned Sappho, who is a lyric poet, aristocratic. Euripides, we've talked about this tragedian. He is writing in the context of the democracy of Athens. So again, he has a different perspective. And then we quoted Socrates,
特洛伊战争的故事才能说得通。因为问题当然是，希腊人有正当理由吗？特洛伊人有正当理由为她而战吗？我认为这也是海伦在整个希腊历史长河中对各种希腊作家如此有趣的原因之一，她为来自不同背景、以不同风格写作的各种作家提供了机会。她提供了素材。所以我们提到了萨福，一位抒情诗人，贵族。欧里庇得斯，我们谈到过这位悲剧作家。他在雅典民主的背景下写作。所以他也有不同的视角。然后我们引用了苏格拉底，
who's this orator who is writing, I mean, he lives a very long life. And as a young man, he's in the shadow of the Peloponnesian War, the great war between Athens and Sparta. And he lives to see the rise of Macedon, which will unleash yet more terrible wars so you can see the power of helen as a mythic figure is that she provides scope for all these kind of different writers to kind of do their stuff and so this particularly this question of are the greeks justified in fighting her i think plays a key role in the birth of history itself so i would argue, Dominic, that without Helen of Troy, we might not be doing this podcast. So we kind of owe her a lot.
这位演说家，我的意思是，他活了很长的一生。年轻时，他生活在伯罗奔尼撒战争的阴影下，那是雅典和斯巴达之间的大战。他活着看到了马其顿的崛起，这将引发更多可怕的战争。所以你可以看到海伦作为神话人物的力量在于，她为所有这些不同类型的作家提供了发挥的空间。所以，特别是关于希腊人是否正当为她而战这个问题，我认为在历史本身的诞生中起到了关键作用。所以我会争辩说，多米尼克，如果没有特洛伊的海伦，我们可能就不会做这个播客了。所以我们确实欠她很多。
Okay. So the two great historians who give birth to history, Herodotus and Thucydides. Thucydides, at the beginning of his account of the Peloponnesian War, the great war between the Athenians and the Spartans, he scorns the very idea that the Greek princes had sworn an oath to get Helen back. I mean, he just says, this is mad. This is a kind of a children's story. And he's very Sandbrook. He takes for granted that the war is a consequence of great power politics and of money. It's fought over material causes. I'm glad that I now apparently own that way of looking at history, Tom. That's very kind of you. Thank you. Yeah, you're welcome. And it sets the template for Thucydides' entire take on history, which is that it is all about, I guess, the masculine pursuits of war and politics. Hey, I'm distancing myself from that because that's not how I do history.
好的。那么，两位诞生了历史的伟大历史学家，希罗多德和修昔底德。修昔底德在开始讲述伯罗奔尼撒战争（雅典人和斯巴达人之间的大战）时，对希腊王子们发誓要夺回海伦的想法嗤之以鼻。我的意思是，他只是说，这太疯狂了。这是一种儿童故事。他非常桑布鲁克。他认为战争是大国政治和金钱的结果。它是为了物质原因而战。汤姆，我很高兴我现在似乎拥有了那种看待历史的方式。你太客气了。谢谢。是的，不客气。这为修昔底德的整个历史观设定了模板，那就是它完全是关于，我想，男性对战争和政治的追求。嘿，我正在与此保持距离，因为那不是我做历史的方式。
No, no, no, no, understood. And this is why in Thucydides, I mean, Helen is one of only 20 women who were mentioned by name and his history is very, very long. There are very, very few women. He wouldn't have been about 60s fashion, would he? No, he would very much not have done that. Yeah. But I tell you who would, and that's Herodotus. Brilliant.
不，不，不，不，明白了。这就是为什么在修昔底德的著作中，我的意思是，海伦是仅有的20位被点名的女性之一，而他的历史非常非常长。女性非常非常少。他不会关心60年代的时尚，对吧？不，他绝对不会那样做。是的。但我告诉你谁会，那就是希罗多德。太棒了。
Herodotus would have loved all that stuff. Yeah. So Herodotus is the first historian and his work, so this is the first work of history ever written, he begins with, in the way that Thucydides will do as well, a kind of demythologization of Helen because he's trying to explain why the Greeks have gone to war with the Persian Empire in the 5th century BC. And he begins by giving the Persian perspective. And the Persian perspective, Herodotus reports
希罗多德会喜欢所有这些东西。是的。所以希罗多德是第一位历史学家，他的作品，这是有史以来第一部历史著作，他以一种修昔底德也会采用的方式开始，即对海伦的一种去神话化，因为他试图解释为什么希腊人在公元前5世纪与波斯帝国开战。他首先给出了波斯的视角。而希罗多德报道的波斯视角是
is that Helen was actually just a number of women who were abducted by pirates coming to Greece and stealing women and Greek pirates going to Asia and stealing women from there. A bout of competitive princess rustling, Herodotus calls it. And there's no mention of Helen's beauty. The Persians just emphasize that the Greeks have massively, massively overreacted to her abduction. And so what the Persians are doing by denying that Helen has any supernatural quality of beauty is to make the Trojan War just look like any other war. It's nothing special.
海伦实际上只是被来到希腊的海盗绑架的众多女性之一，海盗们偷走女性，而希腊海盗则去亚洲从那里偷走女性。希罗多德称之为一场竞争性的公主抢夺战。而且根本没有提到海伦的美貌。波斯人只是强调希腊人对她的绑架反应过度了。所以波斯人通过否认海伦具有任何超自然的美丽品质，使特洛伊战争看起来就像任何其他战争一样。没什么特别的。
There's nothing mythical about it. There's nothing kind of supernatural. I mean, to be fair, Tom, there must have been lots of wars and there must have been lots of violence along that seaboard because there are all these states and cities that are trading with each other. So the Persians surely are just employing common sense. Well, so that would very much be how Herodotus would frame the Persian perspective. He's saying that the Trojan War was nothing special. It was just a kind of sequence of endless tit-for-tat conflicts.
没什么神话色彩。没什么超自然的。我的意思是，公平地说，汤姆，在那条海岸线上一定发生过很多战争，一定有很多暴力，因为有所有这些相互贸易的国家和城市。所以波斯人肯定只是在运用常识。嗯，这很符合希罗多德构建波斯视角的方式。他说特洛伊战争没什么特别的。这只是一系列无休止的以牙还牙的冲突。
And it was ridiculous for the Greeks to overreact just because somebody stole a woman from them. So that is how Herodotus is framing the Persian take on it. But he hasn't finished with Helen because there are two more perspectives that he offers later in his history. So the first is a very, very weird aspect of Helen's story, which is that actually she never went to the Trojan War at all. She spent the whole period of the Trojan War in Egypt. And Herodotus gives an Egyptian account, he says, that this is what happened, that Paris had taken Helen, behaved very badly, and that in the opinion of the Egyptians, the Greeks were right to go and get her back. But that Paris and Helen, when they were going the Egyptians, the Greeks were right to go and get
希腊人仅仅因为有人从他们那里偷走了一个女人就反应过度，这太荒谬了。这就是希罗多德构建波斯人对此看法的方式。但他还没有讲完海伦的故事，因为他在历史后期还提供了两个视角。第一个是海伦故事中一个非常非常奇怪的方面，那就是实际上她根本没有去参加特洛伊战争。她在特洛伊战争期间一直待在埃及。希罗多德给出了一个埃及人的说法，他说，事情是这样的，帕里斯带走了海伦，表现得非常糟糕，在埃及人看来，希腊人去把她夺回来是正确的。但是帕里斯和海伦，当他们去埃及人那里时，希腊人去把她夺回来是正确的
her back. But that Paris and Helen, when they were going to Troy, had been blown off course, had ended up in Egypt. And the pharaoh had been so appalled by what Paris had done that he wouldn't let him leave without keeping Helen himself. So this is why Helen spends the whole time. And in due course, Menelaus comes and picks her up after the Trojan War and goes back to Sparta. And Herodotus says, well, you may wonder why Homer doesn't mention this, if this is what happened. And he says, well, Homer doesn't mention it because it wouldn't have made for a kind of
夺回来。但是帕里斯和海伦在去特洛伊的路上偏离了航线，最终到了埃及。法老对帕里斯所做的事情感到非常震惊，以至于他不让他离开，除非留下海伦本人。所以这就是为什么海伦一直待在那里。后来，墨涅拉俄斯在特洛伊战争后去接她，然后回到了斯巴达。希罗多德说，好吧，你可能会奇怪为什么荷马没有提到这一点，如果事情是这样的话。他说，好吧，荷马没有提到它，因为它不会为他的诗歌带来一种
epic quality for his poem. So basically, he's not revealing the actual truth because it makes a better story to imagine that Helen actually was in Troy. Can I ask a question about Herodotus? Does Herodotus think this actually happened? By which I mean, does Herodotus believe that Helen of Troy is a historical figure rather than purely a mythological one? Yes, he does. He never doubts that.
史诗般的品质。所以基本上，他没有揭示实际的真相，因为想象海伦确实在特洛伊会构成一个更好的故事。我可以问一个关于希罗多德的问题吗？希罗多德认为这真的发生了吗？我的意思是，希罗多德相信特洛伊的海伦是一个历史人物，而不是纯粹的神话人物吗？是的，他相信。他从不怀疑这一点。
He's ventriloquizing the Persians. They accept Helen existed. The Egyptians, they accept Helen existed. But what he is doing is giving multiple perspectives on who Helen was and is. So interestingly, Herodotus thinks that Homer has fictionalized what was previously a factual story. Yes. And you may wonder, well, if Helen spent the whole time in Egypt, why were the Greeks and Trojans fighting then if she was never there? Yeah, mugs. And the answer to this, which gets teased out in a lot of dramas, Euripides inevitably being to the fore, is that the gods created what was called an eidolon, which is a kind of an image of Helen conjured up out of cloud and smoke that looks exactly like her. And that therefore the Helen who is fought over at Troy is a phantasm. And it kind of makes it even worse. They're not even fighting over Helen. They're fighting over a fantasy of Helen.
他在为波斯人代言。他们接受海伦存在。埃及人，他们接受海伦存在。但他所做的是提供了关于海伦是谁和是什么的多种视角。所以有趣的是，希罗多德认为荷马将以前的事实故事虚构化了。是的。你可能会想，好吧，如果海伦一直待在埃及，那么如果她从来不在那里，希腊人和特洛伊人在打什么？是的，傻瓜。这个问题的答案，在很多戏剧中被揭示出来，欧里庇得斯不可避免地处于领先地位，那就是众神创造了所谓的“幻影”，这是一种用云和烟变出来的海伦形象，看起来和她一模一样。因此，在特洛伊被争夺的海伦是一个幻象。这让情况变得更糟了。他们甚至不是在为海伦而战。他们是在为一个海伦的幻想而战。
So that is Herodotus' kind of refinement of the Persian position by giving the Egyptian position. But then finally, he gives the Spartan position. What do the Spartans think of Helen? And Herodotus reports that there's a place called Therapne, just outside Sparta, and that the Spartans, whose daughters are invariably beautiful, Spartan girls are famously beautiful, that if a child is born, a girl is born who is ugly, the nurse will take the girl up to the shrine of Thrapney. And he gives a specific instance of
这就是希罗多德通过提供埃及人的立场对波斯人立场进行的修正。但随后，他给出了斯巴达人的立场。斯巴达人怎么看海伦？希罗多德报道说，在斯巴达郊外有一个叫塞拉普内的地方，斯巴达人的女儿们总是很漂亮，斯巴达女孩以美丽著称，如果一个孩子出生，一个女孩出生时很丑，护士会把女孩带到塞拉普内的神殿。他给出了一个具体的例子
this. The daughter of a king, baby daughter, gets taken up. And the nurse meets a woman there who is veiled. And the woman says, show me the child. And the nurse refuses. And the woman insists over and over again until finally the nurse hands the baby girl over to the nurse. And the mysterious woman strokes the girl's head and then says, you will be the fairest woman in Sparta. And sure enough, the girl grows up to be the fairest woman in Sparta. And it's clear that this woman is Helen. And it's very strange because Helen is playing the role of a god. And it is a direct contradiction to the Persian perspective, which is saying she's just a woman. In the Spartan perspective, Helen is not just the most beautiful woman who's ever lived, but she is divine. It is just one of a number of markers of Spartan devotion to Helen
这个。一位国王的女儿，女婴，被带了上去。护士在那里遇到了一位戴着面纱的女人。那个女人说，让我看看孩子。护士拒绝了。那个女人一遍又一遍地坚持，直到最后护士把女婴交给了护士。神秘的女人抚摸着女孩的头，然后说，你将成为斯巴达最美丽的女人。果然，女孩长大后成了斯巴达最美丽的女人。很明显，这个女人就是海伦。这非常奇怪，因为海伦在扮演一个神的角色。这与波斯人的视角直接矛盾，波斯人的视角说她只是一个女人。在斯巴达人的视角中，海伦不仅是有史以来最美丽的女人，而且她是神圣的。这只是斯巴达人对海伦奉献的众多标志之一
as almost a goddess. There's the fragments of the egg, which we talked about, which are kept on the Acropolis. There's a shrine dedicated not just to Helen herself, but to one of her sandals, which supposedly fell off in the elopement. In a battle, the Spartans are said to have fought. She appears alongside her brothers, Castor and Pollux, to help inspire the Spartans to victory. And you mentioned before whether the story of Theseus abducting Helen was merely a product of the Peloponnesian War, of the rivalry between Athens and Sparta. I think not, because there is a story told that when the Spartans invade Attica, they burn everything and they attack every town except for a place called Decalia. And the story is that they
几乎像女神一样。有我们谈到的蛋的碎片，保存在卫城上。有一座神殿不仅献给海伦本人，还献给她的一只凉鞋，据说是在私奔时掉落的。在一次战斗中，据说斯巴达人战斗过。她和她的兄弟卡斯托尔和波吕克斯一起出现，帮助激励斯巴达人取得胜利。你之前提到忒修斯绑架海伦的故事是否仅仅是伯罗奔尼撒战争、雅典和斯巴达之间竞争的产物。我认为不是，因为有一个故事说，当斯巴达人入侵阿提卡时，他们烧毁了一切，并攻击了除一个叫德凯利亚的地方以外的每个城镇。故事是他们
do this because it was the Decalians who had told Castor and Pollux where their sister was to be found. And so this is a tribute to it. Right. So just on this thing about Helen and her divine powers or whatever, how normal is this for somebody who's reputed to be the child of a mortal and an immortal? So normally do those people have divine powers or normally are they ranked with mortals? They're normally ranked with mortals. There is a masculine counterpoint, which is Heracles, who is also a son of Zeus. Kind of like the most masculine of men in the way that Helen is the most feminine of women. Heracles is the strongest of men. And in the end, he becomes a god and sits in Olympus.
这样做是因为正是德凯利亚人告诉了卡斯托尔和波吕克斯他们的妹妹在哪里。所以这是对它的致敬。好的。关于海伦和她的神力之类的，对于一个被认为是凡人和不朽者之子的人来说，这有多正常？通常这些人有神力吗，还是通常他们被归为凡人？他们通常被归为凡人。有一个男性的对应物，就是赫拉克勒斯，他也是宙斯之子。有点像最阳刚的男人，就像海伦是最阴柔的女人一样。赫拉克勒斯是最强壮的男人。最后，他成为了神，坐在奥林匹斯山上。
And Helen is clearly the female counterpart to that. But it's important to emphasize that there are lots of heroes who have shrines to them, very few women. So in that sense, Helen really is someone unique. And we don't have stories really, apart from very late ones, of her ever dying. And so I think that there are scholars who say that perhaps Helen was always a goddess, that she's a goddess who kind of becomes mortalised. But if that is the case, then there's nothing in the ancient sources that suggests that right you don't believe that you don't believe that that's no i don't i think that just as helen's beauty drives men mad in the myths i think she she's an object of such fascination and to women as well as men so that story of the
海伦显然是女性的对应物。但重要的是要强调，有很多英雄有神殿供奉他们，很少有女性。所以从这个意义上说，海伦确实是独一无二的。除了非常晚期的故事外，我们真的没有关于她死亡的故事。所以我认为有一些学者说，也许海伦一直是一个女神，她是一个某种程度上被凡人化的女神。但如果是这样的话，那么古代文献中没有任何东西表明这一点，对，你不相信这一点，你不相信那是，不，我不相信。我认为就像海伦的美貌在神话中让男人发疯一样，我认为她也是一个如此令人着迷的对象，对女人和男人都是如此。所以那个故事
nurse taking the baby up the idea of of a woman with such power, it's so interesting to people that they think her attributes must be those of a goddess. And so the more that stories are told about her, the more she comes to take on kind of divine attributes and qualities that in a mortal might be condemned, kind of rushing off with strange men or whatever. In a goddess, that's the kind of thing goddesses would do. And so it kind of removes Helen from the dimensions of the traditional standards of judgment that are applied to women. So hold on, Tom, where did she begin? I know you're going to say you don't know, but I'm asking you to speculate. Did she begin as a character simply in a story who over time took on more and more
护士把婴儿带上去，关于一个拥有如此权力的女人的想法，这对人们来说太有趣了，以至于他们认为她的属性一定是女神的属性。所以关于她的故事讲得越多，她就越开始承担起某种神圣的属性和品质，这些品质在凡人身上可能会受到谴责，比如和奇怪的男人私奔之类的。在女神身上，那是女神会做的事情。所以它在某种程度上把海伦从适用于女性的传统判断标准中移除了。等等，汤姆，她是从哪里开始的？我知道你要说你不知道，但我要求你推测一下。她最初是否只是故事中的一个角色，随着故事的讲述和重述，她随着时间的推移承担了越来越多的
semi-divine attributes as the story was told and retold? Yeah, I think so. And do you think she began purely as a male fantasy figure in stories? Well, we'll come to who the historical Helen might have been in due course, but I think she is clearly, even by the time Homer is writing about her, she is already very firmly established as a figure that everyone knows about. That's why Homer doesn't need to explain who she is. And I think the idea of the most beautiful woman in the world who has a power over men that is of a divine order, I think that that appeals to something very profound in the way the Greeks understand the cosmos and the universe. Greek men understand the cosmos. Well, women as well. I mean, because Sappho responds to it. And kind of a fascinating
半神属性？是的，我想是这样。你认为她最初纯粹是故事中的男性幻想人物吗？嗯，我们稍后会谈到历史上的海伦可能是谁，但我认为即使在荷马写她的时候，她也已经非常稳固地确立为一个每个人都知道的人物。这就是为什么荷马不需要解释她是谁。我认为世界上最美丽的女人对男人拥有神圣秩序的力量的想法，我认为这触及了希腊人理解宇宙和世界方式中非常深刻的东西。希腊男人理解宇宙。嗯，女性也是。我的意思是，因为萨福对此做出了回应。而且是一种迷人的
example of the way in which Helen comes to seem like a kind of jealous and angry like a god. There's a poet called Stesichorus, and he writes abusive poetry about Helen, calling her a prostitute and adulteress and so on. She blinds him as punishment, as she had blinded Homer, who supposedly was blind. But Stesichorus is a favourite of the Muses, and so unlike Homer, he understands why he's been struck blind. He composes these lines, "'The story I told is not true. He's addressing Helen. You did not go in the well-bent ships. You did not reach the citadel of Troy.
海伦开始看起来像一个嫉妒和愤怒的女神的例子。有一位诗人叫斯特西科鲁斯，他写了关于海伦的辱骂性诗歌，称她为妓女和通奸者等等。她作为惩罚让他失明，就像她让荷马失明一样，据说荷马是盲人。但斯特西科鲁斯是缪斯女神的最爱，所以与荷马不同，他明白为什么他会被弄瞎。他写下了这些诗句，“我讲的故事不是真的。他在对海伦说话。你没有乘坐弯曲的船只。你没有到达特洛伊的城堡。
So he again is saying Helen never went to Troy. He's basically saying all the stories that are told about Helen are not true. But he's doing this because he knows that Helen is a figure so powerful that she can blind him. And this is what gods do. And I think that this is part of what makes Helen so fascinating to the Greeks is the idea of a woman who stands midway between the human and the divine. And it comes to express itself in very weird ways. So there's a sect of Pythagoreans who basically think she's an alien. So they say that she comes from the moon and that on the moon, there's a colony of humans who are kind of infinitely more beautiful, infinitely larger, infinitely stronger than mortals down on earth. And that this is why Helen is so beautiful. So, I mean, that's a kind of very weird idea. And you get an echo of that. Dan Simmons, the great science fiction writer, he wrote a couple of books, Ilium and Olympus, in which the Trojan War is restaged.
所以他再次说海伦从未去过特洛伊。他基本上是在说所有关于海伦的故事都不是真的。但他这样做是因为他知道海伦是一个如此强大的人物，以至于她可以让他失明。这就是神所做的事情。我认为这就是让海伦对希腊人如此着迷的部分原因，即一个站在人类和神性之间的女人的想法。它开始以非常奇怪的方式表达出来。所以有一个毕达哥拉斯学派的教派，他们基本上认为她是外星人。所以他们说她来自月球，在月球上，有一群人类，他们比地球上的凡人美丽得多，大得多，强壮得多。这就是为什么海伦如此美丽。所以，我的意思是，那是一个非常奇怪的想法。你得到了那个的回声。丹·西蒙斯，伟大的科幻作家，他写了几本书，《伊利昂》和《奥林匹斯》，其中特洛伊战争被重新上演。
And Helen is, again, she's a figure of beauty conjured up by science by that point. But you get a prefiguring of that even in classical antiquity. And I think that it's another marker of Helen's power that you don't need to believe in the Greek gods to be obsessed by her. You know, the stories of Helen continue to be told right the way through the Christian era. I mean, Marlowe is doing it. Yeats is doing it. And Helen comes to obsess people.
海伦再次成为一个由科学创造的美丽人物。但你甚至在古典时代就得到了那种预兆。我认为这是海伦力量的另一个标志，你不需要相信希腊神灵也会被她迷住。你知道，海伦的故事在整个基督教时代一直被讲述。我的意思是，马洛在做，叶芝在做。海伦开始让人着迷。
And you were asking, you know, was there a real Helen? Of course, into the 19th century, when archaeology as a discipline is starting to be developed, the question of was Helen real, it inspires what is probably the most famous or indeed infamous episode in the history of archaeology, kind of ranking alongside Howard Carter's discovery of the tomb of Tutankhamen, which is the German businessman turned archaeologist Heinrich Schliemann in the 19th century, who is so besotted by the idea that Helen might have existed and the Trojan War might actually have been fought over her, that he sets himself the task of going to the site of Troy and trying to find it.
你问，你知道，有真正的海伦吗？当然，到了19世纪，当考古学作为一门学科开始发展时，关于海伦是否真实的问题，它激发了考古史上最著名甚至臭名昭著的事件，某种程度上与霍华德·卡特发现图坦卡蒙墓并列，那就是19世纪德国商人转型的考古学家海因里希·施里曼，他被海伦可能存在以及特洛伊战争可能确实是为她而战的想法所迷住，以至于他给自己设定了去特洛伊遗址并试图找到它的任务。
So Tom, what an exciting moment that is. Schliemann is on his way, this German businessman, to the site of Troy, and he thinks he's going to discover the truth about the Trojan War and the truth about the historical Helen of Troy. And do you know what? We will come to this in our next episode, where we will talk about what Schliemann found, his theories, who the real Helen of Troy might have been, and then we will turn our attention to Helen's possibly even more terrifying sister, Clytemnestra, and her blood-soaked career. And we can talk a little bit about what it all means, Tom. So if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, if you're one of the Olympians, you can listen to that episode right away. And you can, of course, join the Olympians by going to therestishistory.com.
所以汤姆，那是一个多么激动人心的时刻。施里曼正在前往特洛伊遗址的路上，这位德国商人，他认为他将发现关于特洛伊战争的真相和关于历史上特洛伊海伦的真相。你知道吗？我们将在下一集中谈到这一点，我们将谈论施里曼发现了什么，他的理论，真正的特洛伊海伦可能是谁，然后我们将把注意力转向海伦可能更可怕的妹妹，克吕泰涅斯特拉，以及她血腥的职业生涯。我们可以谈谈这一切意味着什么，汤姆。所以如果你是《历史余谈》俱乐部的成员，如果你是奥林匹亚人之一，你可以立即收听那一集。当然，你可以通过前往 therestishistory.com 加入奥林匹亚人。
You get more benefits, frankly, than you would by being a Greek god. We think of our members as Greek gods and goddesses, don't we, Tom? We absolutely do. Midway between the mortal and the divine. Absolutely, they are. So, Tom, thank you very much for that tour de force on that Hellenic and Olympian bombshell. We will leave you and we will see you next time for the truth about Helen of Troy and her extraordinary sister, Clytemnestra. See you then. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
坦率地说，你得到的福利比作为希腊神得到的还要多。我们把我们的成员视为希腊男神和女神，不是吗，汤姆？我们绝对是。介于凡人和神性之间。他们绝对是。所以，汤姆，非常感谢你对那个希腊和奥林匹亚重磅炸弹的精彩讲解。我们将离开你，我们下次见，了解关于特洛伊海伦和她非凡的妹妹克吕泰涅斯特拉的真相。下次见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。